- From health care to
education to advertising,
data is helping businesses
innovate to new heights.
A key challenge is not
just how to find data,
but how to make it useful.
Data scientists
and data engineers
often need to build data
pipelines to ingest, process,
and analyze their data.
These ETL and ELT
type workflows usually
involve multiple
services that need
to be coordinated and
executed at the right time
and under the right conditions.
In our previous
video, we learned
about how orchestration is
the automation, management,
and coordination of workflows.
In this video,
we'll focus on how
you can orchestrate your data
workflows in Google Cloud using
Cloud Composer.
This is where Cloud Composer,
Google Cloud's fully managed
orchestration service,
comes into play.
You can use Composer to
create, schedule, and monitor
end-to-end workflows
using Python.
Composer is built on the
open source Apache Airflow
Project, which has a huge
community of contributors
and users.
And since it's a
fully managed service,
you don't have to worry about
managing Airflow deployments.
Composer takes care of
infrastructure management
for you, so you can focus on
actually building your data
pipelines.
Composer supports many
different use cases,
but most of its users
are data engineers
who are building workflows
to orchestrate their data
pipelines.
There are several key advantages
that Composer has for the data
workflows use case.
First, the Airflow Project
has hundreds of operators
and sensors you can use.
These make it easy
to communicate
across multiple
Cloud environments
with very little code.
In addition to Google
Cloud operators,
there are multiple operators
for other common interfaces
like MySQL and Slack.
Second, Composer has
sophisticated task management.
You can parallelize and
branch tasks and define
how you want to handle failure.
For example, you could send
out an email to the team
if something goes
wrong along the way.
And third, keeping
track of your workflows
is straightforward with
Composer's built-in monitoring.
All of this is important
as your workflows scale
and become more complex.
And finally, Composer comes
with enterprise-ready security
features, like customer-managed
encryption keys and VPC service
control support,
enabling organizations
to use it right away
without worrying
about security compliance.
It's important to note
that Composer is not
designed to transform,
process, or pass along
large amounts of data.
Instead, Composer is great
for managing and coordinating
tasks delegated to other
products that handle your data.
Some products you might want
to coordinate using Composer
include BigQuery, Dataflow,
Dataproc, and Data Fusion.
These are all great at
operating directly on big data.
Let's take a look
at an example use
case of how Composer can use
to orchestrate a big data
pipeline.
Composer tasks are defined in
the form of a Python Directed
Acyclic Graph, or DAG.
First, we monitor a
Cloud Storage bucket
and trigger the pipeline as
soon as the file appears.
Then we kick off a
Cloud Dataflow pipeline.
Next, we execute
BigQuery SQL job
to validate the process data.
And finally, we
delete the object
from the Cloud Storage bucket
since we no longer need it.
Along the way, if
anything goes wrong,
a Slack notification could
be sent to team members.
And there you have it.
Data orchestration is becoming
increasingly important
for data engineers
and developers
to manage their
tasks and services.
By having Composer orchestrate
workflows on their behalf,
data engineers can
focus their efforts
on the more creative
aspects of data engineering.
Make sure to check out the
next video in our series, where
we'll learn more about
how to build workflows
in Cloud Composer.